what a w this was for the head coach of
the arizona cardinals and everybody else
in the organization cliff kingsbury back
here in the rich housing show how are
you coach
i'm doing well thanks for having me on
you got what was that flight home like
it was it was good um our guys were
excited i think
um you know we have some veteran
leadership that came out here for a
reason and with a purpose and um they
were really really excited how week one
went i'm sure uh the the name jj watt
rolls off the tongue certainly when
you're referring to veteran leadership
that came
to arizona what has he brought to the
equation
cliff kingsbury he's really lifted up uh
the entire building i mean when he walks
in whether it's the weight room or
meetings or you're on a zoom i mean he
is intense he's looking you in the eyes
he's taking notes and and that's been a
great example for the young players in
this this organization uh none of us
want to let him down coaches and players
and and you feel that you know every
every day that he shows up well and then
aj green is another but i want to put a
pin in that for the moment and just
focus on the defense and what chandler
jones did yesterday is all-time
single game stuff um coach what what
have you seen in
in chandler what happened yesterday and
it's not an outlier but i just want to
i guess lift the hood up on his
performance right now he's been
phenomenal in training cam i mean to the
point where certain practices it's
almost like hey let's hit chandler out
so we can get a pass off
that dominant um so
it's when you see that in practice and
you think you know what you're saying
and then it shows up on sunday that's
always rewarding for a coach and he
really set the tone in that that game he
had a tackle for a loss on henry the
very first play of the game and then got
the strip stack that that put us in
position for more points there early and
he was phenomenal i assume he got a game
ball
he did he did there's no doubt
that's one of those where did whoever
hand you the ball for the game ball or
you there was probably no discussion
about it right like that's i mean yeah
they hand you the note i didn't even
know how many sacks he had and said five
sacks i'm like jesus really you didn't
you did i didn't know at the time you're
just on the sideline watching you you
know he's killing it but you don't know
the exact steps yeah and then two forced
fumbles too i mean just insane i mean
you've been around the sport have you
seen anything like that
that that's the best performance i've
seen from a pass rusher um you know as a
player or or a coach it was phenomenal i
mean he he dominated the entire day and
then your quarterback did as well uh as
well cliff kingsbury here on the rich
eisen show what did kyler work on this
non-playing season that he brought to
bear in tennessee in week one
really consistency and approach uh last
year we had our moments we had our
flashes we didn't finish the way we
wanted and i think we both recognized we
had to be more consistent
you know how we approach week in and
week out and then have a great game plan
and attack and that's what he did
whether it was his his feet or his legs
he was aggressive and and uh played
downhill the entire game what's he like
man i mean
walk me through what he's like that
he's intense i mean ultra ultra
competitive
he affects perfection each and every day
um and and he he carries a chip on his
shoulder and you feel that at practice i
mean he wants to do it right all the
time he wants to win all the time and
and there's definitely an intensity that
you feel so where do you think that does
that come from i mean you've been
obviously around him for a very long
time with your
college coaching days in the state of
texas i'm sure you were you had your eye
on him for a very long time where does
that come from
yeah i mean it starts with his dad his
dad is super competitive was a
tremendous college quarterback there at
texas a m and just raised him that way
whatever sport it was whether it's
baseball basketball football i mean he
was always raised to be the best and and
when and he really hadn't lost many
games prior to to getting an nfl and i
think um that was part of the learning
curve was hey it's not always going to
be pretty in this league there's really
good teams you came to the last place
team and it's going to be a process and
he's had to learn to kind of battle
through that
and when it comes to his uh ability to
throw and run
i mean how how much do you i mean there
was one play if i'm not mistaken where i
think the next gen stat number on the
number of times that the amount of uh
yards he carried before throwing it was
over 40 like something insane like that
something stupid like that yeah
phenomenal phenomenal play call there
just to have him run 40 yards prior
isn't it i mean
you're a genius i mean but
i take all the credit for me what's that
like for you on the sideline when you're
it's a lot of no no no yes you know i
mean having worked with patrick and
johnny um i mean those guys they make it
fun to because they can turn a bad play
call into a good one real quick and
that's what what kyler did on that play
and you're referring to mahomes and
manziel in that far okay yeah
what do you say to kyle when you see him
next after playlist high five him nice
job bud
keep it moving i mean those guys that
have that ability i learned that a long
time ago you don't want to pull the
reins too tight if they can make plays
like that let them let them do their
thing well i mean there is a coaching um
aspect to this where you got to know
when to push the pedal to the metal and
say let's not do that or like screw it i
mean i got
i got a stallion here that i need to
ride uh as well and let him do what he
wants to do i'm wondering what that's
like
yeah i mean like i said i was fortunate
enough to learn that early in my
coaching career um case keenan was the
first one he's got those quick feet can
escape extend plays and he would he
would turn really bad play calls by me
into really good plays and um since then
i've just learned hey if they have that
ability i mean there's there's a certain
line you walk but you got to let them
play the game cliff kingsbury here on
the rich eisen show i assume you saw um
sunday night football did you catch any
of it were you back home for any of it
i wasn't i wasn't i didn't get to see it
okay let me give you a scouting report
um if you don't if you know like this is
my my way of thanking you for calling
into the show i appreciate that okay
here's the first thing and get a pen if
you want yeah make sure you're taking it
take your notes matthew stafford can
sling it um that's number one um just if
you are you taking this down or i got it
okay
okay uh you're taking mental notes and
and also i'll be very honest with you
it's really ridiculously loud in that
building this is going to be something
for you i mean i i think i even saw like
sean mcveigh had to really yell you know
what i'm saying into his right you know
he's always a yeller in general i know
that right he talks it's it's
very vocal he's i know he's loud just to
begin with even i'm sure when you're at
dinner with him you just like gotta tell
him to keep it down you're just ordering
dinner sean you know you can't tell me
to keep it down
that doesn't work is it true he bagged
you once to to made it seem like you
were tampering and and he changed
somebody's number on his phone to say
roger goodell and made you think that
roger goodell called i still have not
forgiven him for that because i had just
got the job and i'm literally thinking
we just lost the first pick of the draft
like i'm getting fired before i didn't
get there what did he do again like what
i think i kind of heard this story what
did what yeah he pulled out his phone
and he's like oh my god dude he's like
look and it said roger goodell and he's
like and roger is saying please tell me
you're not with patrick mahomes at
dinner
and i'm like oh my god and he's like
dude he never texted me this is not good
and so he played it up for a little bit
and then i about melted in the chair and
then uh he let me know it was a joke
okay so then when you're laying it on
thick on the rams we know why like
that's that's the way it's going to go
it's not perfect we'll do our best they
have a really good team so we'll see how
that one goes well the reason why i
bring it all up is like i think the nfc
west is the deepest end of the nfl pool
there's no doubt about it and i'm
wondering what you think about the
competition clearly you can only take
care of your own house but i'm wondering
uh if any of that thought creeps into
your mindset as you get ready for
another game this coming week
you definitely see the scores week in
and week out i mean you have some
tremendous quarterback plays and
tremendous offensive minds pete carroll
is one of the greatest coaches of all
time whether it's college or the nfl and
so you you see it and then when you play
those games i mean you know it's going
to be a dog fight week in and week out
and it's really helped us grow as an
organization since i've been here
because you know i mean there is
no easy sundays once you get into
conference play and then your receiving
core is off the charts cliff kingsbury
here on the rich eisen show can you give
me um something you've seen
from deandre hopkins where you sit there
and think okay this is why he's
this great like you got a moment for me
yeah i would say just his i mean he's
like an ex man with his hands like his
hands are the biggest things i've ever
seen and then his body control and the
way he can adjust the ball when it's in
there i've never seen anything like it
and he's
super super competitive
um when he goes out there on sundays i
mean he wants the ball every snap he'll
let you know the play caller he wants to
buy every snap he will
yeah he'll he will tell you directly um
and he's probably not wrong most of the
time
that makes it makes it fun to code no i
know that it's just i'll be honest um as
somebody who has maybe or may may not um
have been wondering why he's not getting
the ball more because of the fantasy
football contest oh for three years
running i honestly i'm wondering if like
because it it you're right like not only
does he grab everything in his catch
radius which is damn near half the field
but i never once think that he's did not
get both feet down never i i agree i
mean we had one yesterday in the back of
the end zone that he he it's like you
don't have to look at the replay like he
he found a way
um and if you're not getting the ball
like i said he will let you know that
that he should be getting it can you
give me an example of that please
i mean i mean i'll give you here's my
impersonation okay ready all right it's
cliff cliff i don't know why you make
this so hard dog all you gotta do is
throw me the ball that's it
why do you make it so hard coach i don't
know i ask myself every sunday
get on the ball well you also have
others there i mean kirk scored twice
yesterday too i don't know if you are
aware of this statistic that it's the
first time in the history of the
cardinals that two receivers had at
least two touchdowns or more that's
never happened in the history i don't
know that
i assumed cause they had bouldin and
fitz here um
for a while so that that's surprising
but yeah christian's been phenomenal we
played him more outside last year he can
play outside inside but he's really
found a role there inside in the slot
and has really played at a high level
all camp and then obviously yesterday
and now i'm going to remove the pin i
put in mentioning aj green earlier in
this interview what has he brought to
your cardinal table coach he he can
still really go um quick twitch size
catch radius and then just a councilman
professional he's been tremendous for
that wide receiver room uh he and hop
both from south carolina have a great
rapport and uh i can't say enough good
things about what aj has brought to the
offense man kym has put a ferrari in
your garage
i mean this
you know yeah i i've heard he he lets me
know he does everybody's letting you
know stuff
what's
um but yeah i i can't say enough good
things he he uh had a real emphasis on
bringing in veteran leaders that could
help us
win now and and obviously it's it's a
good group and they're fun to be around
and they've done a great job of setting
an example for this roster all right i'm
going to finish up with a question again
i don't usually ask this of of a head
coach in the national football league
but how's your house how's it going
how's that it's good
yeah the housing prices are
booming in arizona okay
and how's the
that the fire pit is that still burning
is that still burning right now
it does it it burns usually only after
winds that's it wait did you light it up
light it up after a w
okay enjoy more importantly though do
you need us to house sit at anything
yeah we're ready to come over here y'all
are always welcome man do a show out
there
don't hurt him don't tell us that we're
driving coach do not feed the animals do
not why are you going to make it so
tough coach
[Laughter]
it ain't that hard
well done
coach thanks for the call let's do this
more often i appreciate it thanks for it
i appreciate it you guys thanks coach
that's cliff kingsbury on the rich eyes
and show mercedes-benz vans phone line
right here after the w against the
tennessee titans so you heard him it's
really simple road trip to arizona in a
mercedes-benz van i mean this endless
brainerd and the sprinter van we go to
arizona we do a couple of shows from
cliff's house we take in the game maybe
from the coaches or the owner's suite
yes yeah hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that watch more right
here